on peut parler aussi du nombre de
parlementaires que nous avons france et
les salaires des parlementaires et les
avantages devant ce petit café de l'orme
l'heure est aux grandes discussions
c'est jour de marché il y à du passager
chacun est invité à prendre part à ce
grand débat voulu non pas nationale mais
populaire c'est bien beau de critiquer
mais faut amener des il faut
effectivement faire des constats mais il
faut aussi amener des solutions elles
sont des pas les balles non loin en
amène une fois les débats à la télé on a
vraiment envie d'y participer et on a
envie d'apporter un peu bas petit
commentaire deux animateurs sont chargés
d'aller à la rencontre des leurres mois
ouvrir la discussion et recueillir leurs
critiques ou leurs propositions comme on
s'est dit que il y avait des lieux de
politique déjà des discussions dans
l'est dans les villages qui s'appelle
les cafés c'était dommage de pas en
profiter
à l'intérieur aussi les discussions vont
bon train des conversations entre amis
sans rapport avec le débat mais aussi
l'occasion parfois de faire entendre ses
priorités mois pour moi c'est les impôts
qui a une grande réforme sur les impôts
les niches fiscales tout ça tout balayer
et tout remettre à plat et repartir à
zéro
le café pour un village c'est une
institution pour le maire comme pour les
habitants il était tout à fait normal
d'en faire le cadre de ces échanges
c'est un lieu de rencontre c'est un lieu
de débat généralement donc c'est le lieu
approprié convoquer les gens dans des
lieux très institutionnel c'est pas la
réalité du monde d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui si on veut vraiment être à
l'écouté ans et entendre les
propositions des uns et des autres il
faut aller là où les gens
brasser des idées pour trouver du sens
au delà des propos de comptoir une
parenthèse informel pour permettre à
chacun ici de contribuer aux grands
débats